so my guest today is a uh comedian and
activist
and author he did something that was not
an easy thing to do back in 2016 i
believe it was when he went to the
middle east and he did this tour
where it sold out 27 different places
dubai beirut cairo kuwait amman
in front of uh the king and the queen of
jordan and we had them on
four years ago we were putting an annual
convention together in las vegas we had
i don't know four or five thousand
people there
and we brought him on and uh he i mean
the crowd
fell in love with them immediately when
this guy's on stage
he lights up but at the same time the
reason why i wanted to bring him on
i respect his opinion i think when a
country like us is in a situation that
is that sometimes we need comedians
comedians can play the role of a
synergist to kind of lighten the load
and get us to say listen
can we all just get along
[Music]
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment thank you for having me
patrick i appreciate you having me on
actually that tour you mentioned
was the access of evil comedy tour it
was in 2007 i appreciate you
yeah i know it's good because as i'm
getting older i like that you kind of
pushed it up a little so now i felt
younger for a second i was trying to i
was trying to make you younger but
2007 so so the talk you gave on
the tedx the one that's got 15 20
million views was that 07
no that one was i believe in 0809 so
the story goes in 07 we went with the
access of evil comedy tour that was me
and three other middle eastern american
comedians and we were the first group of
guys who came out on comedy central
who were from our part of the world
doing stand-up and i always say it was
the first time you saw middle easterners
on american television and we weren't
killed
we were just telling jokes and um so
that tour
took us to the middle east and it was
amazing like you just said we got we got
a chance to do
27 shows over 30 days the king of jordan
showed up at one of the shows
and that set us off and then after that
we kept going back
and the ted talk that you're talking
about that has something like 15 million
views
happened a couple years later in doha
qatar
which i'm sure you've been to yes it's a
beautiful it's a smaller version
of let's say dubai but it's still
beautiful state of the art and uh
and that what i love about that ted talk
is not just the fact that oh i gotta go
got a chance to go do this ted talk but
the fact that they did it in doha so
when they go to the audience
you see people dressed in the
traditional
arab garb and they're laughing
and to me that is a message that i think
we should share around the world that
people from that part of the world love
to laugh just like anywhere else and by
the way you were not holding back
i mean you were you were you were taking
shots at everybody and it was the
the best seven minutes of comedy uh some
of the best seven minutes of comedy
that's out there i enjoyed watching it
but
here's a simple question for you you're
smart you're eloquent
you're very well spoken you're you have
a great processor you're witty
how do you as an iranian not become a
doctor or lawyer or a dentist or an
engineer how do you do this how do you
become a comedian
patrick i tell you as soon as you said
smart witty all that stuff i was ready
to just hang up and say i'm one i'm done
i'm out of here
no you know man uh you know our parents
did not want this
i always i jokingly say i say when i
first did this
i disappointed my dad i disappointed my
mom i disappointed the entire iranian
community
because you know i would hear them
talking behind our backs and they all
thought that this was going to be some
big disappointment and i jokingly say
that
we would go to parties and i could
overhear people going did you hear about
jobrani's son
he's almost a drug dealer because to
them comedy
may as well just be drug dealing you
know and um
23 years ago when i started doing this
patrick uh
there were not other iranian americans
doing it
um not to say that it was anything that
i was groundbreaking it was just that it
was
the thing that was groundbreaking for me
was doing what i love to do
because you know how it is you run into
fellow iranian americans or
fellow immigrants kids of immigrants
whether they're indian or chinese or
whatever
and if they're not doing lawyer doctor
engineer that's
that's in a way it's going oh wow you
went against
the norm and so for me what happened was
my parents wanted me to be a lawyer be a
lawyer be a lawyer be a lawyer
and i didn't want to be a lawyer since i
was 12 years old i was on stage i loved
being on stage i wanted to be like eddie
murphy
i did plays i was always on stage and
i'll be honest with you because of my
parents pushing me
when i was in my mid-20s it took me
until i was 26 years old when i had the
light bulb moment and i go you live
once so you got to live for you you got
to do what you love doing
and make yourself happy once you make
yourself happy then you can make those
around you happy
and then if you're really lucky you can
make those who
don't know you happy that's not easy
that's
yeah that's that's not only not easy to
do it's tough to be aware of it
especially when you're younger because
it's such a
and you know the middle eastern culture
is a very pressure
type of an environment you know it's not
like it's a
judgmental type of an environment not in
a negative way it's just a
high standard high expectation and you
kind of want to be pressured
to deliver for the people you love the
most but at 12 years old
you're following eddie murphy you kind
of want to be the next eddie murphy
if i'm in high school with you at 14 15
years old who was mar
maz at 14 or 15 at 14 15 you know i've
always been this person who
i get along with everybody so i i love
sports so i played soccer and i played
baseball so i had my friends that were
the jocks
i loved being on stage so i had friends
who were the
drama friends right i was a i was always
nice to people i
don't think i got in any fights in high
school so i had friends that were
from all walks of life and i personally
the reason i became a comedian was
because i was a fan of comedy
so my closest friends were funny so i
love being around these guys and i'll be
honest with you
patrick there's people that i grew up
with that were definitely funnier than
me
but they just didn't have the vision or
the drive
to end up doing what i ended up doing
because i knew from a young age i go i
want to be
on that stage in that on that screen
that's what i want to do so
i was able to get to where i am because
i knew where i wanted to go
so you said 23 years ago in 1998 is that
kind of when you first started is that
is that your
yeah so up until then i was doing plays
i was keeping my toe in the water while
i was trying to keep my parents happy so
i was gonna go be a lawyer
uh and then while i was in uh college my
junior year i went and studied abroad in
italy
for one year and i tell every young
person i go if you can go study
abroad go get out of here go to another
country
experience it you grow exponentially
it's one of the best years of your life
but while i was there i go oh there was
a professor i liked what he was doing so
i said maybe i'll come back and become a
professor
so i come back and tell my parents i'm
not going to be a lawyer i'm going to be
a professor of political science
and right there my mom goes what are you
talking about like yeah my mom goes
there's no money in being a professor
i go mom how do you know about the
market for professors you don't know
what you're talking about so anyway
started grad school to get my phd in
poli sci
while i was there i started doing plays
again and so i always had my toes
in it always had my toes in it and then
again what what what
i was telling you um i eventually
dropped out of grad school
went to an advertising agency and just
got a job as an assistant at the
advertising agency
but still kept doing plays so i'm doing
the play
uh at that time and i have a video of
the play and i'm
in the ad agency making a copy of the
video
for the other actors in our play and
while i'm doing that there was a guy by
the name of
joe ryan now joe was older than me he
was in his 60s at the time
he was a really nice guy very always
very uh um
supportive and he goes hey maz you're
funny have you ever thought about
getting into acting and comedy i go joe
throughout my life i wanted to do it my
parents kept pushing me in another
direction
i said you know in the next few years i
may go for it and he goes let me talk to
you he takes me into his office
he sits me down he says maz listen to me
i'm in my 60s
and he goes when i was in my 20s i
wanted to do some things and he goes i
never got around to doing it wow
because if you really want to do it you
got to go for it and that was another
light bulb moment
that joe ryan gave me great counsel
that's it and that moment was then i i
enrolled in
in comedy classes and i started going
and that was again 1998 i just
i i went to my boss i said listen man
i know i'm working for you at the ad
agency but now my priority of in my life
is going to be comedy and acting so if
you want me to quit i can quit and he
said no you can stay
until you get stuff but that was the
light bulb moment 1998 joe ryan
and the rest was history so so political
science was that because
that's the route to being a lawyer
because you had interest in politics
no it was more the route to being a
lawyer i and and for me i'll be honest
once i signed up for that i
really found it very interesting because
you start learning history you start
learning about how
government works you start learning a
lot about about a lot of stuff and it
opens your eyes you know as an
iranian-american
i grew up in in america trying to avoid
my history and my background of iran
because i wanted to blend in with all my
american ki
uh friends you know whenever my parents
would show up with their thick persian
accents i was like oh no
they're going to give away the fact that
i'm iranian and
my friends are going to know that i'm
not american but
once i went to college and i started
studying stuff i go oh my god america
had a hand in overthrowing
a democratically elected leader in iran
and you know you start learning the
history of what god is where we are and
i think it's good because
especially nowadays you know we forget
history and if we don't
remember history we are going to repeat
the errors and the mistakes that we've
made in our past
and so i i think it was a um
a a a good major for me to to take
it's interesting what you just said
america had a hand in overthrowing a
democratic leader
uh in iran we'll get to that here in a
minute as well because i kind of want to
see some of your thoughts there because
i know behind every comedian i sit with
or i speak with the deeper you go
listen every one of them has a glimpse
of genius it's it's not easy to be a
comedian comedian is not
like to be able to have the second you
have to come up and be witty and come
you know
it's not an easy job to do but let me
let me ask you one question about
98 to 2008 to 2015 to
2021 how much has the industry of comedy
change in that 23 years
well the industry's changed a lot and
it's interesting because
i have young people asking me questions
sometimes how do i get started what do i
do
the basics are still there it's like if
you watch let's say
baseball you know the the and you ask a
baseball player they say yeah you got to
really get good with your swing and you
got to work on your infield and you got
to work on your throat you know the
basics are still there and the basics
for comedy
i tell everybody if you want to be a
stand-up comedian the basics are
get on stage as much as you can and
write as much as you can and what i mean
by that is when i say get on stage as
much as you can that means you got to
get on stage
five maybe 10 times a week and you do
any number of minutes like some clubs
will say oh you get three minutes
when you start out they might say you
get three minutes you get five minutes
you get 10 minutes now you get 20
minutes
but you got to do all of that and and
when i say
write as much as you can you don't want
to be in this business for 20 years and
be doing jokes that you did 20 years ago
because people are going to lose
interest and also you as a human being
are going to grow
so i have jokes from my first solo
special was called brown and friendly in
that's when my son was born so i have
jokes of my son
as a baby now my son is 13.
but if i'm on stage doing jokes about my
son as a baby
and i'm still doing i i feel like a
fraud
so get on stage as much as you can write
as much as you can however
the way the industry has changed is now
more than
ever you can be in control of your own
destiny
because when i started you had to go get
this there was a booklet with all the
agent names
hopefully an agent sees you get into a
club maybe somebody sees you you move up
the ladder of the club etc etc that's
how there was no
social media even myspace was maybe new
or hadn't even started yet
but now you can end up in any
social media format that you choose to
you can go and get a fan base i know
comedians right now
who don't have that many years under
their belt as comedians
but they ended up on let's say clubhouse
or on tick-tock or on one of these
things and they ended up with
a hundred thousand five hundred thousand
a million followers the clubs are
booking them
so these guys have grown their own
business now they need to grow
into their into the level of delivering
in the business because you could have
the fans but if you don't have
the years under your belt they're going
to come see you live
and about 30 minutes in you're going to
be out of material and they're going to
go where's the other half an hour of the
show
yeah and and pros catch that fairly
quickly you're gonna
you can probably tell when somebody is
winging it and they haven't really
prepared for it
uh i'm assuming when you when you're in
the space like you
not just us the audience can tell so the
audience shows up listen the fact is the
audience sees you this was happening
early on when that show
um last comic standing was happening
sometimes you'd have comedians
who had less experience but they were
winning
on that show and so audience members
would tune in on nbc and see a comedian
do
three minutes and go oh i love this guy
and then they go see him live and they
realize oh he doesn't have more than the
three minutes or more than 20 minutes or
30 minutes so
it's disappointing to the audience
member as well comedy is a
is a is a art form where you really
can't fake it
and you can't you very rarely see a
young success in comedy in music you
could be 15 years old
and have the voice of an angel and have
a producer find you and say let's go
make music
and you could be 16 years old and just
be a superstar
in stand-up comedy you got to put in
five to 10 years before you really start
finding your own point of view stand-up
comedy is about having a point of view
it's about delivering that point of view
and very rarely throughout our history
have we seen
really young successes eddie murphy dave
chappelle chappelle started at the age
of 14.
so by the time he's 21 he's already
hitting it right so
but it's a rare thing usually with
comedians you got to you get to your
mid-20s
early 30s before you start seeing some
success because
listen patrick when you first start out
in stand-up
you're off stage you and i are talking
when i first start out in stand-up when
i go on stage
you would see the person emulating
the hero their comedy hero so i'd be on
stage trying to be like eddie murphy i'd
be on stage trying to be like richard
pryor
but the longer you spend on stage and
and finding your voice the closer the
person off stage becomes of the person
on stage and eventually what ends up
happening is
that's how some of my writing happens
because i get so comfortable
with who i am on stage that i'll be off
stage talking to a friend of mine about
something that happened
and without even trying i'm writing my
material
because i'm expressing my opinion off
stage the same way i would on stage and
then so do you get off right off the bat
and say [ __ ] i just said a joke i've
never said before let me write it down
so i can remember
are you doing absolutely i do that or
what i do is i often
record my sets on stage and so what will
happen is
especially in la in la we do uh
continuous comedy which means because
you're in la or new york where you have
you know all headliners on a lineup at
the comedy store or the laugh factory or
the comedy cellar all these places
you're gonna see headliner after
headliner after headliner
and we each do 15 to 20 minutes well in
that 15 to 20 minutes i say to myself
okay i'm gonna do
10 minutes of material that i've done
before and
five minutes of newer stuff to try it
out i'm gonna sprinkle it in
so what will happen is i'm recording it
in case the stuff that i sprinkle in
works then i go back and i listen to it
i go oh that worked that way
great oh don't forget to add this little
element
to that joke so that's how it's working
so i'm listening
i'm recording it all the time on my
iphone make sense
you know in hollywood what do they call
a triathlete you know triple threat you
can dance
you can act you can sing what is a
triple threat in comedy is there such a
thing as a triple threat or no
i mean comedy i was i compare comedy to
boxing because in boxing
you can do the heavy bag you do the
speed bag you can shadow box you can you
know jump rope there's so many different
things you can get better at endurance
you can get better at
you know your agility there's so many
different places in
boxing that you can work out and get
better and better at
similarly with comedy there's so many
different facets to it
you can become a better writer by
writing and writing and writing
you can become more charismatic on stage
by just getting on stage getting more
and more comfortable you can get better
at crowd work crowd work to me
is the clothes is very similar to boxing
because you're throwing something out
and they're throwing something back and
you got to react off of that
and that that's a muscle you got to
exercise for me early on in my career
when i became a regular at the comedy
store mitzi shore who owned the comedy
store made me a regular and what that
meant was
throughout the week they would put you
up on their lineup
and since i was new they weren't going
to give me the best
spot of the night they were going to
give me the last spot of the night so
i'd end up
on stage at 1 30 in the morning when the
club's going to close at 2
and at 1 30 in the morning you can't go
up and just start doing your act and say
oh my girlfriend broke up with me and
no 1 30 in the morning it's you and five
people
in the audience so you just start
talking to them you go why are you guys
here where are you from you're from
sweden what's that like and
that conversation and coming back and
forth you're working out this muscle
so that later on down the line when
you're in front of a thousand people and
you're doing a show
and a lady gets up in the middle of your
act and starts to go to the bathroom
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
be like hey where you going and start
talking to her
and the crowd's gonna love it because
you know you're on it and i actually
compare that a little bit
to surfing as well which is when we
start doing crowd work
it's like surfing if you catch a good
wave you know in surfing i think
the what what they do in surfing is
they're in the moment because you're
that wave's coming you catch it you're
on there i
i guarantee you there's no surfer on a
surfboard who's thinking about their
taxes
thinking about their you know oh did i
leave the did i leave the iron on
no that surfer's in the tube and going i
got to get through this
similarly with stand up if you're doing
crowd work and you catch that wave
sometimes patrick i'll say things that i
didn't even
think about it's my my instincts just
saying it
and then the laugh comes and i go what i
just say and i go oh okay that's cool
because i'm in the moment you know yeah
so so that's that's interesting so
better writer better on stage crowd work
i can see that
uh which of those three is the hardest
one to learn is it is it the writer
uh is it better on stage like you know i
guess some people learn through watching
somebody and mimicking their body
language and how they move and how fast
they run in certain things they do
from your experience for comedy which
has been the hardest to duplicate
well for me i'll be honest since i
started doing plays at the age of 12 i
got into the
the junior high school musical and they
taught us how to stand on a stage one of
the things a lot of
actors don't realize when you're on
stage you got to open your body to the
audience you got to make sure they can
see you
and similarly when you do stand up you
got to make sure the audience can see
your face i've seen comedians show up
they pull their hat down over their eyes
and you can't even see their expressions
so they're not thinking
about that stuff so there's a stage
presence for me
standing on stage was the easiest part
from day one
being on stage was fine having energy on
stage was fine
for me the writing was the hardest
because i always thought well what am i
going to write about
how do you write how do you know the
rhythm of writing and it took me a while
but eventually you start realizing hey
you got to write what you know because
you're the only one who knows that
experience
so whatever that is uh you know and it's
my point of view
listen if i'm doing a joke about being a
dad there might be another dad comedian
who's got a similar joke
but if it's coming from my experience
then it's my experience and i can tell
you that joke
makes sense and and the other thing
about writing comedy there's a rhythm to
it
it's like a math equation it's almost
like
it's got to be there's a rhythm so as
fellow comedians sometimes we'll sit in
the back of the room
and watch a comic do his act or her act
and afterwards we'll go over and say hey
when you did this this and this
have you thought about saying this
afterwards and they say oh that's cool
let me try that out
and similarly comedians will come to me
and say that they go when you do this
you should do that so
we all know the rhythm now yeah for me
writing was probably
the more challenging part of it but now
i feel very
comfortable why because i know my voice
as a matter of fact
i try to challenge myself sometimes by
sitting in the back of the room
and seeing if i can write for other
people and if i can
that to me if i give if i give what's
called the tag
to their joke to their punch to their
joke if i can give someone a tag
and it works that's almost more of a
sense of pride to me
than giving myself a funny joke got it
because it makes you
multi-dimensional where you can now kind
of uh
watch somebody and know what the next
move would be it's almost like in a
movie you're watching saying the next
line should be this
and if you say before they say it you
know it's like hey
it's a it's an element of writing the
script let me ask you in in the game of
sports
in basketball in football you'll see the
video of kobe bryant doing all the
shots that he makes and they'll put it
right next to jordan it's like
exact kick same time you know turn same
time and then you'll see
jordan stole the move from dirk nowitzki
where he goes out and kicks it out and
you know the shot or you know you're
seeing booker right now taking a couple
of foot work from
kobe and it's a very normal thing in a
game of sports right that people do that
but stealing jokes in comedy that's like
the ultimate
what is it with comedy and the amount of
controversy sometimes you see
when it comes down to somebody using
somebody else's jokes
where is the you know crossing the line
to say listen man you took my joke
that's mine that's not cool
you see you know the whole i've had
carlos mancia on before you've seen the
carlos mission
broken back and forth from god knows how
many years ago was why is that so
serious in the comedy industry
well you know doing the technique for a
shot is different right because there's
only certain ways you can shoot i mean
you know
you're not gonna have uh um you know
kevin durant jump in this
jump in the air to do a jump shot and
spread his legs wide and
you know make a funny face and throw it
up and it goes in there's a technique to
it right
so that's the technique similarly with
stand up there's techniques to
certain things again like i said there's
techniques to
being present on stage if you look at a
bunch of comics you'll see the ones who
are high energy have kind of a similar
uh um way of presenting themselves but
the jokes themselves
that stealing that the analogy would be
let's say in basketball
it wouldn't be so much oh you are doing
the same move that i'm doing
but it's almost like saying you
you are you know you've been watching my
press conference and saying the same
things i say
or even going one step further it's
almost
it's i would almost say it's like you
took my trophy
because because our jokes are are what
make us
that's our story i spent you know blood
sweat and
tears to write my act my act is
my act now if you go especially this
happens
unfortunately where a bigger act will go
and see
an unknown act and say oh i like that
and then they'll go do that on tv and
now they've put their stamp on it yeah
and this poor kid who's been working you
know
working as the as the doorman at the
club and getting three minutes
of stage time once a week he just had
his whole
act that it took him a year to build
stolen from somebody and that person is
doing it on tv
that is just a total no-no and in
stand-up
you know it's closer to what what they
do with music when
when a lot of musicians go oh you took
that riff that i did and you put it in
your song and now you're making millions
of dollars
uh-uh ain't gonna go um you know i
looked up
you know the in michael jackson mama
saying
i looked it up and that was an african
singer who had a song that said mama
it was that's a whole thing
and it's funny because supposedly
michael was doing the song and at some
point
he started riffing because the song has
nothing to do with mama
he just started saying mama makusa the
song takes off
this guy shows up and goes whoa that's
my song you can't just do my song in
your song
so that's the thing and and in comedy
listen the the one good thing because i
matter of fact early on when i first got
into comedy i was talking to somebody i
said
isn't there a way for us to copyright
our jokes so that nobody else can take
them and unfortunately there is
no you know government entity where you
could say oh here's my copy written joke
you know you can do that with your
scripts you can go to writer's guild of
america not comedy
probably you can't but the best the best
thing you can do is
get it out on a special and once it's
out on a special and it's there
and if somebody comes and says oh you
took that joke from so-and-so you're
gonna know i did that joke in 2008 and
here's the proof
and that's all we can do so and by the
way by the way one last thing
joke stealers eventually
we they get ratted out so the comedy
that all comedians know who the joke
stealers are
would it be fair to say it's kind of
like you watch you know you see uh
uh they'll show joe biden and johnny
carson shows a video of joe biden you
know
telling the same exact speech of a
somebody in a britain
parliament says it or a even ivanka
trump when she gave the speech and they
went and said michelle gave the speech
just a few years ago similar to it
is it similar to that when politicians
kind of give the same would you would
you use that as an analogy
absolutely it was melania trump and it's
it is plagiarizing yeah
it is plagiarizing especially if listen
the problem with comedy by the way is
you know i always i always say i'm
jealous of musicians because a musician
can have a concert
and at some point they can go uh i'm
gonna sing this song from the rolling
stones and they just sing a rolling
stone song
and they just say that was and everybody
knows it's a rolling stone song and they
say i'm gonna do it
a comedian can't be on stage and say i'm
gonna do an eddie murphy joke now
this this next segment is eddie murphy i
can't just do that
you know that would be so awkward i can
see that part
you know i'm gonna tell this joke from
uh you know george carlin it's
my favorite joke he said but i think i
can say it better than he does you know
yeah i had a guy one time told me he
said uh i like your marketing strategy i
want to kind of use it myself do you
mind if i use it
i said yeah sure he asked permission i
thought it was respectful i said you can
do it in chicago i was dressed as
george washington and i had this event i
had my wife dressed as lady liberty
and you know we were acting out certain
thing i came out as a
general a patent from george c scott you
know the movie pattern yeah and i did
the whole five minute skit
it's like i want to be able to do this
in my event of chicago i said go ahead
and do it
i said what's your gift he says my gift
is i get to see people who have
come up with ideas but i can do better
than they do with the idea that they
came up with
i feel like sometimes there are certain
people in the comedy world that maybe in
certain business are like
i can probably take that guy's joke and
do it better than he's doing it
with the uh with the platform that i
have i don't know i think sometimes yeah
i don't care yeah i don't care how good
do you think you
are you can't take someone else's first
of all there's there's there's
two sides to this one is you're taking
that poor guy's joke
and going and doing it secondly though
you
have to live with yourself that you've
stolen someone else's joke
that isn't a sincere thing coming from
you so eventually
that's got to start eating away at your
own sense of
self-worth or your own sense of being a
comedic um
creator because it goes again it goes
totally opposite to what i told you a
second ago about
sitting in the back and saying oh i want
to write extra jokes for this comedian
because i want to be able to tell people
i'm good enough to write jokes for other
people
when you start stealing jokes you're
saying i'm not even good enough to write
jokes for myself
i'm stealing jokes from other people and
that's gotta wear away at your self
self-worth and your self-confidence to
go god am i a fraud i mean really
ultimately i think that happens
underneath you know and so i think in
every industry you're going to get
exposed if you do that
there's ways to get exposed in every
industry i always say a bad idea
always gets exposed it doesn't matter
you can it can convince you
for a minute for six months twelve
months eventually five six seven years
later people gonna say this is not a
good idea i don't support it
and that happens in every business let
me tell you this too before you leave
that i was going to say
as a comedian there was there was a
comedian named freddy soto who was
one of the funniest people i ever knew
and unfortunately we lost him like
10 12 years freddy soto freddy soto soto
if you look him up he was this
mexican-american comic
out of el paso he was a regular at the
comedy store he was a guy i looked up to
and he was
brilliant um and i remember one of the
first times
that i got a good um
encouragement i was at the comedy store
it was late it was like one one of those
1 45 in the morning spots
and i didn't know freddie was sitting in
the way back because the room is very
dark mitzi sure used to make the room
really dark
and put lights in your eyes so it would
blind you
and the reason was she didn't want you
to see too much of the audience to feel
self-conscious she wanted you to feel
like you're doing comedy into a void
right and just just be you so
um at that point there was three people
that were in the club that i could see
on the side and it was two nerdy guys
with one really hot girl and so i went
on stage i was newer to comedy so i just
started doing my act and then of two
minutes in i go
i'm thinking to myself why am i doing my
act i i turn to them i go
i'm curious how did you two end up with
her what's the story here
the next thing you know i'm having fun
with them they're laughing
we're i'm making jokes off of what
they're telling me
i have a fun time we call it a night the
whole club ends and they leave and the
lights come up and i see freddy soto was
sitting in the back
so i go sit next to freddy and he says
hey man you're funny i go thanks he goes
you know
he goes i've realized comedy is not
about bits
he goes you're either funny or you're
not and he goes you've got
you've got the comedy the the the thing
and he also said he goes
you know if if it's just one bit that's
going to make you
then you're not then forget it so
similarly
if you have someone i've had people say
oh so-and-so stealing a
bit you used to do i go well that's fine
i got a thousand other bits
and i'm gonna keep writing and if that
that's that person's problem
you know i'm not so because sometimes
comedians will say oh my god it took my
bit
and it's their end of their life no you
better you better have more than one
[ __ ] yeah
you know ray kroc the founder of
mcdonald said something very interesting
one time
they asked him a question they said hey
so how do you feel about the fact that
everybody's stealing your idea
you know with this whole franchise model
and what you've done with mcdonald's he
says you can take our system
you can take everything you're doing you
cannot take our mind and our heart away
from us
we are very good in business so at the
end of the day
you're going to find out who the real
business people are just like in your
world when freddie
soto said you're going to know who's
funny and who's not you figure that part
out here's a question and ray kroc by
the way i saw the movie ray kroc stole
the thing from the other guys the two
brothers that he bought it from
you know yeah yeah so talk about that
guy that guy you know the two brothers
didn't have a vision they didn't want a
skill this guy wanted to scale and he
wanted to be known as
the founder and uh yeah you know it is
what it is so
but going back to a guy like you in
every world
you know we like to see redemption
stories i'm curious to know what you're
going to say since you're in this space
redemption stories robert downey jr goes
away for a few years he comes back he
crushes it
and we love that story you see it in
sports a guy goes away he comes back
he does very well for himself you you
you think
a mancia has a shot of redeeming himself
in the comedy world is it too late for
him
gosh i think with mencia like i think
from what i've heard
i i haven't run into him from what i've
heard he's doing fine
in the clubs and he's got his fans the
thing about comedy is
you can i mean if you get if you get
burned in the
industry it's hard to come back
depending on what it
is political or no is it a it's it's
political but it's also like what it was
so robert downey jr had addiction
problems and he comes back and people
are rooting for him they're like oh we
want you to do better right
but if you if you get caught for
plagiarizing or stealing
unless and i'm talking about in the
industry now unless he were to come back
and say i'm going to make a movie
about a guy who lost everything because
he got caught plagiarizing and then he
grows and he comes
back and you know he realizes he's going
to be himself or he does a one-man show
about fabrication you know
something yeah southern but also like
showing that there's growth i mean
maybe then um but the good thing about
being
a comedian or a performer that tours is
your fans
love you i mean you're going to lose
some fans because of that but you're
still going to have some hardcore fans
i mean mencia is still a great performer
gives a great show
so i'm sure that he's doing great on the
road i don't know about
the redemption in the business per se
simply because of what i just said
unless if they come up with i mean
listen it's hard enough to make it in
this business
without having to have redemption
because you know i've been doing this 23
years
i've sold like three or four different
shows and this and that but it's never
gone
to the you know to tell you know on on
air because
it's hard to make it now much worse if i
had
done something that had a black check
mark against me
and now i want to come back i almost
feel like you gotta address
that thing in your comeback yeah i you
know kevin hart and i were but you know
when
when he came out with the responsible
tour i had him out as well i think i had
him out the year after you or
two years after you had them i don't
know what it was but were you 2017 when
you came out and you performed
i ca i did 2017 2017. i remember we were
talking off air
the thing about when you came out which
was special is the week before your
performance
i remember we got a call and you know
your your sister
uh uh passed away right which was right
we and
we were having a conversation my guy's
like pat this is what i said whatever
maz wants to do
moz gets to tell us what he wants and
it's his choice and you still
chose to come and people walked
everybody knew but within the first
two three five minutes everybody knew
and i said like this guy's a
one a pro but it was great to see you
come out there and do what you do with
the audience i remember when that whole
thing took place with you but we brought
heart a year later or maybe two years
later
and he did the irresponsible tour and he
kind of went up there and he talked but
listen
first time i messed up i'm glad i messed
up but the second time i messed up i
really messed up you know he went out
just said this is what i did that's what
i did
and you're saying take a page out of
kevin hart's playbook
to see if you even stand the chance to
make a comeback
yeah i think you need to address the
elephant in the room
right so if i for example of whatever
got caught for embezzling money
and i did i mean richard pryor is a
great example richard pryor
set himself on fire trying to smoke
crack
and then he went on stage later and did
an act where he talked about setting
himself on fire and he made it funny
because he goes you'll never run faster
than when
fire's chasing you and it's on your back
and whatever he did
you have to address it you have to
address it somehow either either in a
funny way or in a sincere way you could
go up
if i had embezzled money let's say i
were bernie madoff and now i've gotten
out i'm doing stand-up
i better have some jokes about it or i
better go on stage and go look guys
thank you for
coming out i appreciate you giving me a
second chance i embezzled all that money
and
you know i i don't know what god and
whatever it is i apologize my time
you have to address it because if you go
on stage and you don't address it
then uh uh you know no one's gonna
people are just gonna be thinking about
it the whole that makes sense i mean you
know we'll see what happened there
we had him on i told him i said why
don't you reach out to rogan over the
internet twitter send him a tweet and so
once you guys get together he never
ended up doing it but uh who knows
what's gonna happen there but it is what
we wish every one of these guys uh
nothing but the best and hopefully
they'll he'll redeem himself but
rogan had a uh we talked about robert
downey jr earlier rogan had him on
i don't know if you had a chance to see
that one when it was uh downey jr and
him if you haven't seen it
it's a great one i mean it's just it's
it's very interesting when they
they're talking to each other joe says
what's off limits today
in hollywood and you know robert starts
kind of laughing and cracking up where
are you going with this and he says the
one movie tropic thunder right he says
oh yeah is tropic thunder doable today
can you do tropic thunder today and
robert says i don't know
you know can you can you not because you
know you know acting like a different
personality and
color and all this other stuff he says i
don't know if we can get away with that
today
uh maz what is the uh is there any
off-limits stories for comedians today
are there stuff that maybe you could
have touched 10 years ago
that you're better off just not touching
today listen man
it's an ever-evolving world i always say
that i think we need to grow as
individuals there's certain words that
were
said in the 50s that you can't say now
there's certain words that we're saying
in the 80s you can't say now
there's certain words that would say
five years ago you can't say now and i
think
on the one hand you know i have kids and
they sometimes
they show me and they
tell me and they lead and that makes me
believe in the future because i go wow
these kids are are progressive
and they see a world where all the
colors come together and it's not about
the color it's about it's about your
character either a good person or a bad
person right so
um i think that we need to grow i think
comedians though end of the day
we get to choose you live and die by the
laugh
so if you sit there and go i want to
tell this joke that's going to be
talking about something that let's say
is derogatory to women or is
misogynistic or
could be construed as racist or whatever
yeah you know if you're that passionate
about it
get on stage and try it and see what
happens because the audience will tell
you either they won't laugh
or they'll get up and walk out or
they'll laugh
you know there's some comedians who push
that envelope
and still come around with a punch line
that makes the audience
go oh my god i didn't see that coming um
and there's some a lot of comedians that
have been you know
cancelled for things they said and the
unfortunate thing is nowadays on social
media too
you might just throw something out that
you think you know very
little about you might say oh whatever
uh gosh it's so dark today
uh blah blah blah and use some
terminology that might be construed as
racist but you weren't meaning it to be
that
but then all of a sudden people are
coming at you and you're going oh no you
know
so that's also a different thing because
a lot of times people take things out of
context and and that's why i always tell
people i go if you're about to go i mean
unfortunately social media doesn't do
this but
i i would say it to the fans of that
person if you're going to
get upset at someone that you're a fan
of look at their
full history so if you know somebody
who's been let's say
an advocate for black lives matter and
has been
an activist and has been vocal
for uh racial equality and all that
stuff and then someone says oh they made
a racist tweet
then look at it and go oh was that an
intentional tweet was that a was that a
mistake
and and don't judge that person off that
one tweet look at their full
story but unfortunately social media
doesn't do that
yeah you know the thing is for for me
like when i was in the army we would
joke and you'd sit there and you always
had the funny guy in the army the army's
filled with funny guys and telling jokes
90 of the jokes would get you canceled
today on any given day if it made it out
on youtube if it was hurt you're going
to be in trouble if it makes it out
but i understand if politicians have to
walk on eggshells i get it okay yes you
chose to go
say you have the solutions to help a
county a city a state
a country yes you every award comes out
of your mouth you're gonna be
judged for it because that's your job i
understand
if a parent fine you're a parent you
talk to your kid in a certain way that
kid's gonna remember for 20 years
but a comedian walking on eggshells like
we got to have a place where
somebody can get up and say what
everybody's thinking about like you know
how you know hey
let me address the elephant in the room
and i'm phone and i was like oh my gosh
you dressed it [ __ ] that was kind of
cool because i was thinking about it
if we can't address the elephant in the
room who the hell can if comedians can't
do it
you know like who else are we going to
rely on to do that pastors
you know listen you're absolutely right
and if you come to the comedy clubs
we are they are like it's the i think
the place where it gets carried away is
when somebody films it puts it on social
media
that person wasn't in the room right
takes it out of context
and it blows up because a lot i've been
at comedy clubs recently and a lot of
comedians are saying things
that could be construed in certain ways
but the audience for the most part
is getting it let me ask you when you're
doing it at the comedy club do you guys
always have it live with the camera on
or do you guys say turn off the cameras
for the most part uh a lot of clubs
don't allow
filming so if someone's filming you
really want to come tap them on the
shoulder
no no we're not you know that's not
allowed because also it's not about it's
not even about oh we're afraid that it's
going to get out and there's going to be
backlash but more importantly
if i'm working on my act so that i can
put it on a special sure
and some bozo comes there and puts it
online and now that thing's already out
there
so now when i go to netflix and go hey i
got this great joke they're going to go
well it's already out there
so that's really the main reason why we
don't want that stuff
and i'll be honest with you i actually
recently had an experience where
i lost a potential job
to a retweet that i did because
this company that was going to hire me i
retweeted something that had to do with
the ceo of the company but i didn't
intentionally i didn't think about it
like years like a while back someone had
done some video and i was like oh that's
interesting retweet that's it
i didn't think anything about it i
didn't care about the ceo of the company
i didn't have any sort of
it was just that the the tweet that i
saw was making a social commentary
um based on um income inequality
and i said okay i could be yeah i'm i'm
for income
income equality sure yeah and so
a couple years later here i am about to
get a job and they come back to me and
they say oh you tweeted something
against our ceo i go what i don't even
know what you're talking about
and they showed me that and it was so
ridiculous
because i i just laughed i said i can't
believe that this like you just said
i have to watch my tongue when it comes
to a retweet on something silly like
this
and similar to what you said i said i'm
a social commentator i should be able to
comment
on what's on my mind and unfortunately
we live in such
fragile times where these kinds of
things happen and you know it is what it
is
yeah for me with that part it's it's
like let these guys leave these guys
alone do what you got to do and uh
offend all of us say whatever you got to
say because god knows some people are
thinking about it now of course there's
certain areas
you don't want to touch that's a little
bit of a distasteful
i get that but distasteful if you're so
distasteful
you're just not gonna make it there's
certain comedy i watch
but i'm like you know what that's just
not funny to me i don't i can't do
anything with it but
i guess some people find it funny i
would never go pi pay to watch somebody
like that speak
but when i listen to chappelle and
chappelle special
comes out and he says let me talk about
abortion yes you ought to have the right
but we should also have it
like oh i never thought about it that
way before you know or john stewart
comes out and says
hey what do you mean this uh you know
the drug is not man-made and he does it
on cobell you're like [ __ ] just about 12
months ago anybody that ever said this
on a video
every video was taken out but he can get
away with it i want stewart
to keep having the ability to do that
because he
has the card of what i am a i don't know
what i'm talking about just a comedian
i don't know i'm just a comedian i don't
know what i'm talking comedians want to
act like they're dummies but we know
comedians are geniuses you ain't no
dummies
comedians are small but we need that i
think we need a little bit of that
and uh the more it gets away from it
yeah that's why i was kind of like
is there anything you guys cannot touch
today where you feel like you're walking
on excels
you saw what barclay said the other day
i don't know if you caught that this was
like a month ago
when barclay said i don't like my job
anymore
and he said what do you mean you don't
like your job anymore he says uh
half the time off camera i'm being told
what i can and can't say what i just
want to talk
i want to have a good time i'm gonna
probably stop doing this in two years
because i'm not having fun anymore
so when you try to silence everybody to
that level as well and it no longer
becomes fun
then the guy doing his job is not having
fun and if the guy that's doing his job
is not having fun we're going to feel
the fact that that person's
not having fun doing their job anyways
that was pretty interesting perspective
you
uh share with us on what the market is
like right now for comedians
so let me go a different angle for you
you're iranian i'm iran
uh you came right before the revolution
do you remember the exact date
when you guys came out here or no do you
remember like i know it was 78 but you
remember the date
uh we came uh i think it was december
of uh 78. wow and
yeah yeah december 17 it was the coldest
winter in new york we land in new york
and
might we we're gonna try and live in new
york but it was so cold my mom said
let's get the hell out of here
and it's funny because as my mom and dad
later separated and divorced et cetera
my dad would say i was gonna buy this
building in new york that's worth 150
million dollars now and your mother told
me not to buy it
i'm like dad get out of here you know
december of 78 wow so yeah do you
actually have memories of living in iran
or no
dude my memories of living right you and
i were talking a little bit about
um um uh rocky so one of my memories of
living in iran
was seeing rocky at uh
uh um like five or whatever the age was
seeing rocky my father was a big boxing
fan
so uh we love muhammad ali i love
muhammad ali one of the reasons i think
why
i do what i do is because of muhammad
ali because i remember
patrick years later when i came to
america i always thought of muhammad ali
as as this amazing boxer but i come to
find out he was an amazing humanitarian
and i remember driving on la brea avenue
when i was working in the advertising
agency
and apple had this ad campaign called
think different they had muhammad ali
gandhi einstein einstein and there was a
picture of that famous picture ali where
he's punching and it's got his fist
and i'm looking at it as i'm driving i'm
an assistant i'm making like twenty
thousand dollars a year doing nothing
and and i i see
the picture ali i go oh my god that guy
touched the whole world
and i go god i i want to do something
where i can affect people
and and that was one of that was all
when it was building up to that joe ryan
moment
and um and i just i just
you know i i loved what he stood for he
had the belt
the championship belt and he goes i'm
not going to vietnam
to kill the yellow man that i have
nothing against and i go that guy gave
up
everything so that is something to
aspire to
to to to to live on your principles so
muhammad ali
uh rocky i remember i had spiderman
uh comic books um i i just i remember a
lot i was
it was a regular you know i don't know
where were you in tehran dude um i think
we were in the north like the nice area
of tehran my father was a successful
huh gandhi i don't know where the area
was but i just remember my dad
was my dad was a successful businessman
my dad the closest
i can uh say is my dad was like uh vito
corleone the godfather people that
needed things would go to my dad he
would help them out
and uh and i always thought like maybe
my dad's exaggerating until when he
passed away
i would run into people who'd be like
listen if it weren't for your father my
family never would have gotten out of
iran
your dad did this he was a very generous
man and so
you know as a kid you know i mean it was
very western
because it was under the shaw so we had
a lot of western influence so as a kid i
just
had a regular almost american upbringing
you know
do you do because i came uh uh i was
born october 1878. so
you're 72 i'm 78 you're february 26th
i'm october 18th so i came uh november
28 1989 right after romani that's how
many died is when we came
uh november no july 15 89 is when we
escaped
november 28th is when we came here in uh
uh
1990 we lived in germany at a refugee
camp for a year and a half
so you see around there you leave iran
because of what's going on with the iran
revolution good timing on your dad's end
by the because at that time i think the
two men was still less than twenty
22 man a dollar later on i mean right
now it's ridiculous if you follow some
of the numbers on what's going on
what what do you think about what's
going on in iran today you know you see
the climate you see what's going on with
water you see them wanting the
revolution you see china came in and
signed a 25-year contract
400 billion 400 billion dollars what do
you think about what's going on iran
today
my heart breaks for every young person
in iran
you know um i've seen this for so long
you know the problem with iran is
it's been 40 plus years of what's been
going on
and so you see this i get people
sending me messages help us i got no i
got nothing you know
and and unfortunately like i was just in
dubai recently and i'm looking at dubai
and i go
geez dubai had no natural resources and
look at what they built in the past
30 40 years and i go iran had all these
resources
iran had and has so much
um capacity of brain capacity i mean
iranian students were coming to stanford
university
to the electrical engineering phd
program and their first year in the phd
program they were saying we've already
studied all this stuff in our undergrad
and supposedly they were like some of
the top students and then the problem is
those guys come and they stay why do
they stay because
they want a better life and they can
find that here but they can't go back to
iran and have that better life because
of the government being oppressive
the government's oppressive against
women against homosexuals
against baha'is against a lot of people
against young people
and it's an unfortunate thing it really
is this
totalitarian state and it breaks my
heart and
the question becomes well what do we do
right how do we help that
how do we help that come out of that now
one solution is to attack iran like you
did with iraq
and get rid of the leadership i
personally i'm not an advocate of war
because i know that
even in iraq they lost i don't know how
many innocent ira iraqis died
right so if you did war with iran you'd
lose half a million a million
people innocent people would have to die
i don't know so on the one hand i go
gosh that's not the solution
on the other hand i go do you try
diplomacy
in which case a lot of people are
against it a lot of iranian americans
are against it because they go diplomacy
with this government
is giving them more power and more
strength
so i really don't know what the solution
is i'm hoping that the people of iran
are able to lead what i hope is more of
an evolution than a revolution because
yes i want this government to go but i
don't want bloodshed
like i mean there is bloodshed already
but i don't want it to be so bad so
in all honesty i just try whenever i'm
faced with any issues i try to just
show my support for the people of iran
currently there's protests
in uh uh who's estan because there's no
water the water's dirty
um and i i did uh on my instagram post i
did hey
i'm i'm with the people of ira uh of
huzzastan and i want the media to cover
this
and i don't know what the future holds
but it just breaks my heart every time i
see the news coming out of iran
complicated the
situation that's going on by the way did
you ever follow feredon faro
or no did you know his story i know his
story because a friend of mine so i i
made a movie a few years ago called
jimmy vestwood american hero
i described that as the persian yeah i
described as like the persian pink
panther it's a bumbling idiot who wins
the green card lottery comes to america
and saves the day it's a silly movie i i
made it for like 12 year old boys
and you know teenagers like it and
adults think it's a little too raunchy
it's a silly movie if you're looking for
a silly movie jimmy vest with american
hero
my co-writer on that is a guy named amir
oh hebsian
he had written a script about uh federal
sod that was beautifully written
and it won an award the movie never got
made because they never had funding for
it
but um what an amazing uh character and
what a
complicated interesting story he had
very complicated and
the way it ended i don't know if you
know the whole story on how it ends in a
hotel
uh what happened to him so last question
i'll ask you before we wrap up here
since
you know you you made a comment earlier
you said the
when you studied poli-sci you were
curious about history because you
noticed a link between us under carter
and the overthrow of a
regime in iran that was pretty much a
democracy following a lot of the
westernized
philosophy under the shah why do you
think when the word
shock comes up you know and how iran was
before why do you think some folks bring
negative connotations to what he did
because
i bet if i were to ask if if i were to
ask you what did your dad think about
the shah
is it fair to say that his assessment
will be more positive than negative
absolutely i think listen the problem is
people see everything black and white
they don't see the nuance of it right
i'll be the first one to tell you as a
kid
in iran under the shah i thought oh what
a great
country and there was a lot of great
stuff that was happening we were
modernizing we were
you know we were we were someone we were
a country to be reckoned with
in the world and headed in the right
direction now at the same time
i'll be objective and say yes under the
shah there was savak the secret police
there was people who would disappear
there was um you know people couldn't
speak
couldn't criticize the shop because
that's just what happens when you have a
king of any country
you can't criticize that king and so
it was it perfect no was it better than
what's going on now
i would argue yes because these guys who
came and took over
really brought in the dark ages i mean
it got even worse
and so i think we should be able to talk
about that and criticize the system
before
without necessarily saying okay now
let's okay now we've done that now let's
talk about the current system
and now let's talk about what's going to
come next let's take egypt for an
example
egypt under hosni mubarak was very
oppressive
um and limited and then they got rid of
mubarak they had elections and this guy
came
in who was a a muslim brotherhood guy
and it got even like as oppressive or
maybe more oppressive
and then they got rid of him and now the
military dictatorship
so the question becomes i honestly don't
know what the future of iran holds
living in a western democracy i
appreciate the western democracies
that's why
the last four years every time there was
an attack and i know our people were
divided on trump and this and that
but anytime there was an attack on the
media or any time there was an attack on
some of our institutions
that existed whether it's the judiciary
or whatever
i always thought wow we're chipping away
at what makes us a democracy so i've
already seen that game play out
under in iran where we got a we got away
from what was already uh
it was already a shaw with some
freedoms and then we got to this thing
that's even darker because we really
like now it's completely controlled
so i'm just someone who's an advocate
for people's voices for democracy and i
think that we should be
willing to it's kind of like the
conversation we're having right now in
america about
critical race theory a lot of people say
we shouldn't talk about the bad things
america did
with slavery or the native americans i
go no
you have to know the good and the bad
and be willing to admit that those
things happened you know it's almost
like saying like oh wow
uh you know you know if you had a father
who was abusive to everybody
oh that guy was such a funny guy yeah
but he used to abuse
mom yeah but he was funny well he used
to hit all the kids he was funny
remember that time he's he stole all the
money from the neighbors but he was a
funny guy let's not talk about all the
listen
no you should be able to look at the
good and the bad
and the shah brought a lot of good but
there was also stuff to criticize him
for so i think
you know we just got to keep uh uh you
know an open mind with that and you
and again not to compare the shot with
these guys are
the worst the current regime
is i mean anything called the regime is
usually a bad thing
and they really are they really are um
i i have zero uh uh sympathy for the
leaders of the government of iran
and uh and and all my heart again goes
back to the people
can you see yourself ever before uh you
know while we're still here do you see
yourself ever performing
in tehran like you ever seen
i would love to the only issue that i
have is i perform in english
and i'm more comfortable performing in
english so even when i go to the middle
east yeah the
the audience has knows english and they
come and they laugh
sure so i would have to find an audience
of iranians that speak english well
enough except
you know what i'm saying oh it makes
sense i mean you know because the
the to be able to pull out words and get
technical i'm sure you have to have a
depth
uh vocabulary and i'm not saying you
don't when i listen to you speak farsi
you speak very eloquently i don't but
i can't see that taking place with what
you're at do you see any
any uh concerns with today like you know
my
my biggest thing is the following here's
what i struggle i'm curious to know what
you think about this
iran so my mother she was a two-day
i don't know if you remember today you
know yeah of course how do you describe
what it is
in iran two days were communists yeah my
dad in iran he was an imperialist so he
was a shah you know he loved the shah he
thought the show was great my mother
shah was terrible and
you know it was they got two divorces in
a span of six years in the span of 20
years they got married
divorced married re-divorced 20 years
beautiful
and probably the best thing that ever
happened it was probably good for the
world that my parents got a divorce
but you know you see uh oh
you see how there is 99 things
to talk about how great america is
but we spend 99 of the time talking
about one percent of what's bad in
america
okay that's what happened to iran you
got
you know women could vote women could
work in anywhere
women weren't forced to get married at
the age of eight or thirteen like the
marriage
marriage age changed and they could go
out there and have their own identities
they had a voice
and then now it changes and they don't
have the voice you know your kid yeah
marry a girl like 13 years old and
you're 42 years old and allah says
that's okay with it right you can do
certain things that's going on like that
in iran
so do you think sometimes over and like
you said crt you said uh
uh there are people that don't want to
talk about the fact that slavery took
place in the past i don't think the fact
that people
have a problem i went to school and i
studied slavery history taught you what
slavery was 30 years but i think it's
the fact to say
you're this you're that this is what
happened because your family is this
because your family is that
do you see the playbook of america going
in a direction where we're spending more
time thinking about what's wrong with
america rather than what's right with
america
no i disagree i don't think that's the
case i think that
we most people know america is a great
country and if they don't they should
travel
outside of america and you'll see
america is a great country
i just think that there's room for
improvement and i think that what you
just said is interesting because
you're right we talked about slavery or
native americans a little bit
in school but they don't go into depth
in it and it's good for us to know
in order to not repeat the past and i
honestly don't think because i've heard
some politicians say
oh you're going to make the white kids
uncomfortable i don't think teachers are
in classes going like hey why kid your
dad did this no
it's saying a good teacher would say
let's look at the history of what we did
there was good white people there was
bad white people there was good black
people there was bad black people
there was black people who were probably
selling out the other black people
so that they could make the money and
sell out these other people
so i think it's knowledge is power right
we should definitely know what's going
on
but listen if you can say whatever you
want about america but this pat
this past election we had the highest
election election turnout
ever so that's a good thing we should
work
more and more towards that to get more
and more people engaged more and more
people
aware of what's going on and more and
more people voting for their own
interests
and as you said let's concentrate on
making america a better place let's try
and attack the homeless problem let's
try and
build on infrastructure let's make
voting easier for people
we have the highest technology right now
you had people
in the administration who were in charge
of voting and said this was the most
secure voting election
ever and you went to judges you went to
several judges
and you look at all that you go geez at
a certain point
we have to say yes this was secure and
it's going to be more and more secure
and let's make it more and more
available to people
so everyone can participate so when the
next election comes around
whether you're a you know uh a grocery
store clerk
or your ceo of a bank you're going to go
and vote because you want to be involved
in part of what you just said
this country being such a great country
that those two people
one of them's making a billion dollars a
year one is making you know 20
a year but they both have a vote let's
let's
let's work towards that and so i don't
think by looking at your faults
you're going in that direction i don't
think that's the case
but i think over emphasizing which is
what the media is doing 24
7 is getting america to have more
bickers and fights than ever before and
i said i'm surprised you don't see that
trend
when you said a good teacher uh you said
you said a good teacher wouldn't say
this
so i think what you are also saying moz
is the fact that we should get rid of
bad teachers we should also have a
opportunity to keep bad teachers and a
lot of bad teachers to get fired
would you agree with that at least some
bad teachers should get fired well i'll
tell you what you know how you get rid
of bad teachers
you start paying teachers more money and
then you're going to attract
the top you're going to attract more
people i'm going i'm for
paying more i am for paying more and
firing the ones that don't
you know don't give their breath yeah
make teaching
a a desirable job so that
people will people with high capacity
will want to be there so
you know um listen man i
the divisions are there and
unfortunately uh but but i see i see
love you know i see people do i i'll be
honest with you patrick i do what i can
on my own
terms like i see you on stage on stage i
do get sometimes political and say my
opinion
but i try as much as i can when i'm in
public i am
i go overboard nice nowadays if i come
to a door
i let the first the other person go
first because i know everyone's
you know under a lot of stress we've had
two years of this pandemic and this and
that so i just go
overboard with being nice and courteous
and i think if more of us do that and
pay it forward
perhaps the world will smile a little
bit i i hope
you guys don't get silenced man i hope
you guys can do what you can do
as comedians and you don't walk on
eggshells because your industry
uh has the ability to unite america i
just today i made an announcement this
morning
at 8am and i sent the video out and i
said uh
i'm willing to give five million dollars
if president
trump and president obama are willing to
sit down together for a long form
interview
to have a conversation together because
i think both of them have their own way
of loving america
they have different ideas why don't you
guys talk to each other for two three
hours
and see if we can figure out a way to
unite this was just uh
probably two hours before you and i sat
down together it's got a lot of
attraction we we're already getting a
lot of things that are coming back
i think we need to be able to hear both
sides whether you agree with it or not i
think we need to be able to hear both
sides
and patrick if they don't agree to sit
down you should hire two impersonators
and give them 50
each save yourself a lot of money and
just do it
it's a good idea body appreciate you for
coming out how can people find you if
they want to find you
what's the point for them to go it's at
maz jobrani
m-a-z-j-o-b-r-a-n-i
at giobrani on instagram tik tok twitter
all across the board
mazjobrani.com is all my tour dates i'm
currently on tour
and my podcast is called back to school
with maz giobrani
so tune in and uh and and follow me
we're going to put all of those links
below folks if you want to go follow
moz click on the description all of
those links will be below
all right thank you so much for your
time i appreciate you truly take care
brother thank you
bye-bye bye-bye industry comedy walking
on eggshells iran
state of america curious to know what
you took away from this interview and if
you enjoyed this
interview i got two other videos i think
you'll like it's my sit down with kevin
hart or carlos mencia
if you've not watched either click on
those interviews to watch them take care
everybody bye